a recent survey revealed that people are
equating the corona virus with Corona
beer not making this up there has been a
massive increase in online searches for
Corona beer virus and beer corona virus
and again this is true some market
experts believe this could affect the
sales of Corona beer so it's very
serious for the corona beer company to
address the situation Corona parent
company Constellation Brands has issued
this new ad I checked it out I don't
think this is gonna help take a look
hello I'm Bill Newlands and I want to
address you the American consumer okay
there is no and I mean zero connection
between the corona virus and this
perfectly refreshing great tasting
germ-free Corona beer why'd you guys
name your beer after a virus that's dub
we didn't we named our beer first the
reason we have the same name is because
Corona means crown in Spanish see the
crown oh so you're like the king of
viruses no stay with me please okay
again there's no connection between
Corona beer and the corona virus how
many cases are there of the beer
Millions
sounds like a pandemic no no again
you're conflating two different things
oh well I know if I have the beer uh I
guess checking your refrigerator or your
hand I have the beer now does this mean
I'm sick absolutely not why should I
trust you well I'm the CEO of the
company what if you are a ghost I'm
alive I'm not a ghost so I'm the ghost
there's no ghost
sorry I just there's there's no there's
no ghost and there's no virus in your
beer so this is a beer that I'm holding
yes
and now I have the virus no virus virus
no it's a beer bottle full of virus it's
a beer Saturday samus virus now with
hero ooh nachos Grande those viruses
it's a beer bar environment farmers
farmers beer beer beer beer
[Applause]